jusque ont comprend pas c'est au bout
d'un moment on sait pas l'erreur qu'ils
ont commise
quelque part ils ont été on a été
délaissée franchement là tu es vraiment
délaissé au bout d'un moment quand la
police est venue nous a demandé de
rentrer chine a compris et puis après
une demi heure plus tard une heure plus
tard il ya 154 g gento ont débarqué dans
la ville
ça nous a et au bout de 48 buts 24
comptablement on a demandé negro ont
fait leur travail avec des acteurs de ce
quartier ont fait leur travail la mairie
a fait ce travail en dix ans attendez
vous inquiétez pas la république et la
police va t'arriver ou de 24 à 48 heures
c'est vrai le temps d'organisation
c'est vrai on peut comprendre ça mais
par contre qu'on nous reproche à nous
quelques éléments population avoir mal
agi entre guillemets pour s'être défendu
ça ça reste quand même une ça passe pour
toi ça va c'est incompréhensible de ne
pas en bien même vous les expliquons
domaine d'un côté ni essentielle pour
l'image de marque de la société pour etc
pour avoir été condamné pour avoir
ils ont retenu un d'avoir mal agi mais
comment quand il ya la peur derrière
quand il ya un sentiment la sécurité
est-ce que c'est légitime pas quelque
part quelque part une protection même si
elle est maladroite la question
la question est là on fera tout cas
monsieur d'abord nous sommes venus à
2000 intérieures pour nous rendre compte
et va compter que citer que s'est il
passé ici deuxièmement je voudrais
qu'ensemble on se trompe pas ça vous
avez dit nous avons été agressés ya des
gens qui ont commis des violences
vous savez qui c'est d'accord il est
coupable les vrais coupables
les vrais coupables ceux qui sont à
l'origine de ces violences on sait qui
c'est et nous appelons est-ce qu' il
soit sanctionnée avec la plus grande
sévérité ils sont venus mettre panique
ici dans le quartier
l'accusé les accusés ce ne sont
certainement pas les forces de sécurité
forces de l'ordre je suis venu voir
elles ont fait leur travail et toutes
celles et ceux qui ont concouru à ces
désordres être punis mais on se trompe
pas de cause monsieur effectué il ya des
gens qui sont venus ici ils sont venus
ici souvent extérieurs au quartier si
j'étais un brin totalement au quartier
et qui sont venus faire des actes
inadmissibles
là dessus on est absolument intraitable
donc la police fait un travail vous le
savez difficile remarquable la police
elle est là pour nous protéger à tous à
tous et j'appelle monsieur le maire est
là c'est pas une action cohérente de
tous
douce de tous surtout qu' on doit faire
cesser prévenir et réprimer ces actions
est donc moi je suis aussi venu ici à
tous à porter avec le ministre un
message d'apaisement
respectons nous les uns les autres c'est
le fondement de la société républicaine
je l'espère et c'est aussi je suis venu
ici à porter à la fois un message
extrêmement clair et à des comportements
qui ne sont pas tolérables dans la
république à dijon monsieur même ou
ailleurs deuxièmement c'est en unissant
nos forces que nous les combattrons
et je veux aussi apporter un message
d'apaisement